benvenuti all'ultima imperdibile puntata
di tentation highland vip
quella di oggi è l'ultima tappa del
nostro viaggio nei sentimenti le nostre
coppie infatti dopo aver spiato loro
amore ma ascoltato il loro cuore
capiranno definitivamente se tornare a
casa insieme o separati
[Musica]
iniziamo subito con una coppia
scoppiettante quella cioè di ursula e
sossio per soste o e ursula è arrivato
il momento di ascoltare il loro cuore
nel falò di confronto finale
ciao ursula allora eccoci al falò di
confronto finale come ti senti quali
sono le tue emozioni sono agitatissima
non vedevo l'ora che arrivasse a questo
momento va bene allora aspettiamo
insieme sossio ti vedo molto bene
fatta la vacanza sono circa dieci giorni
che aspetto questo momento tra i cosa ti
dico grazie per avermi portato a cannes
parliamo di cose serie soffio questo qua
è legato prima di entrare qua c'è ancora
il tuo profumo che una presa per il culo
regalo la sala regalano no dallo quello
stronzo di giorgio alfieri e ragazzi
ragazzi un attimo allora proviamo a
confrontarci serenamente quindi con
serenità per favore ha iniziato ad
aggredire perché ha la coscienza sporca
che non può fare altro la prima parola
offensiva verso la mia persona la mia
famiglia la mia intimità io me ne alzò
me ne vado
va bene so se allora inizi tu e poi
ursula avrà diritto di replica
hai mancato di rispetto a mia madre che
hai mangiato sul suo piatto a casa sua
ha iniziato al carico umiliarmi e ci
credo come mi ha trattato soffio come
siamo arrivati qua soffio cosa mi volevi
fare di più di quello che mi hai fatto
il nostro cosa cosa adesso piange come
vedi anche sono donna anche che sono
fragile anche sono debole
mi ha fatto soffrire soluzioni ma per
cosa per tutto quello che mi hai fatto
da quando siamo arrivati io con sarah
non ci ha fatto niente ma se l'ha
corteggiata per 20 giorni sembra v.to il
tentatore
io ero di la vedevo tutto soffio mi devi
far spiegare i non ha fatto niente
perché lei non ha voluto fare niente se
non l'avesse fatto sostiene no non ci ho
mai provato a non c'è mai provato ci
sono i video sul stio hai detto non
voglio uscire a mani vuote ma quanto sei
sfigato che non riesci neanche a stare
da solo sossio spiegato è uno e uno ma
perchè non fai pace con il cervello
soffio ascom ascolta muscolare di
moderare il linguaggio mi devi far
parlare perché
ragazzi io capisco la rabbia però così
non arriviamo veramente da nessuna parte
è allora ursula tu sei una donna ferita
più che una donna rabbiosa molto che ha
ferito perché io credevo in lui perché
io pensavo che lui fosse il software che
mi stavo vivendo da cinque mesi e adesso
cosa ti fa piangere ursula la cattiveria
la cattiveria caputo con tool merito che
non sono un uomo che sono un animale ma
che caridi ma se lo penso tozzi oscura
maghetti rivista incazzate questa ride
ma metti la testa posto pensa parti una
famiglia non ha pari in latin lover una
cosa ti avevo detto io non parla cretina
con giorgio alfieri e tu vai fard io non
ho fatto la cretina soffio ma quello sai
che per me c'è solo amicizia
ursula e ci da sola o in compagnia di
social da sola sossio e quello che
volevo anch'io quindi assolutamente per
una cosa devi sapere io esco col
sentimento car house ma lo devi sapere
non è tutta colpa tua
sarà ma ora sarà sarà
e adesso occupiamoci di una coppia
stellare che più stellare non si può
quella di valeria marini e del fidanzato
patrick per valeria è già pronto un falò
l'ultimo prima dell'infuocato confronto
con il fidanzato padrin valeria allora
tu sei rimasta molto amareggiata perché
patric chiha detto che più che un
fidanzato tu hai bisogno di
un'assistente sì sì ma allora questa
cosa che ha detto a fa veramente ridere
cioè mi fa capire che è lui non ha
veramente capito niente di ma vale o un
video per te così potrai chiarirti
meglio la situazione padana
ricordo quella volta che eravamo in
discoteca con mia figlia e c'era anche
anna anna falchi elan dalle palla
valeria la tua figlia segreta valeria se
incazzata perché ha detto al massimo mia
sorella
io voglio solo cose stellari io sono
sempre sola sola è una vita che la sento
dire così ma basta
no no sì no scusa possa interrompere
basta cioè io veramente sono senza
parole
sai la cosa che mi fa più male è che ha
il tono quasi invidioso cioè come se
fosse astioso capito
cioè io la cosa della fia poi non è vero
assolutamente cioè avanzi è offerto di
lavorare di fare la modella guarda ha
inventato una marea di bugie io sono
sotto choc veramente non me l'aspettavo
mentre valeria torna al villaggio con
bum bum bum bum bum bum di pensieri
patrick è pronto per il suo ultimo farò
in solitaria patrick non ti nascondo che
ho altre immagini da farti vedere ci
credo ci credo fa bello che ti dico c'è
un freddo pazzesco che bello qua sotto
tutto caldo punto sei dolce
non ho parole c'è un percorso proprio
ridicolo
con questo chiudiamo il cerchio
veramente sono senza parole
ci siamo è arrivato il momento stellare
valeria marini sta per incontrare dopo
21 giorni il fidanzato patrick patrick
sono passati 21 giorni come li hai
vissuti questi giorni ma sicuramente
riflettendo ho riflettuto tantissimo
bene allora aspettiamo insieme valeria
va bene
ciao ciao prego prego allora patrick ho
sentito delle cose che hai detto che mi
hanno veramente ferita
cioè mi hai fatto pure il verso sempre
da sola sempre da sola non hai toccato
nessun argomento che riguardasse noi
cosa che hai fatto tu invece vero cioè
tu mi dovevi dimostrare veramente che mi
vuoi bene
certo dopo quello che ho visto io vero
perché scusa cosa hai visto
cioè io ti ho voluto mandare solo delle
provocazioni ammazza dal primo giorno
io non ho fatto niente che ti ho mancato
di rispetto a patrick ma tu stai
scherzando
ma tu stevie proprio in una bolla di
vetro ho visto 16 big vuoi 16 si dai
video in cui scherzavo con ivan un
ragazzo con cui ho trovato delle
affinità un bravissimo ragazzo
scherza lì vi siete chiusi tre volte in
bagno e allora stavamo solo parlando
sì certo vi siete nascosti dietro lo
scoglio vi siete messi sotto la coperta
vi siete baciati ma va ma che ci siamo
baciati ma va dai a no io ho fatto tutta
la luce del sole
cioè io non mi devo nascondere ma anche
io ma tu sai del tutto resti sentire
quello che dicono le fidanzate di te sai
e deve sentire cosa dicono invece
fidanzati dite sì vabbè sotto
adesso capisco perchè sei amico di son
solo come si chiama dai
innanzitutto si chiama soffio zonzo
d'orzo
no non si chiama john doe si chiama
soffio vabbè tondo fosse uguale ma poi
cosa c'entra questo con il nostro
rapporto
vogliamo andare al sodo benissimo il
discorso che tu non puoi pretendere
amore se non lo dai
ascolta io d amore ne do tanto e l'ho
dimostrato più volte nella mia vita che
so dare amore preparato solo di lavoro
di io che lavoro tutto il giorno che
dormo tre ore a notte sono di
stupidaggini e parlato
io le dico invece le fai io le faccio di
conseguenza a te patrick hai fatto la
bambina che portava come una quindicenne
ma cosa fleur tavo ma cosa fleur tavo da
valeria posso farti una domanda allora
spiega patrick cosa ha rappresentato
ivan per te allora ivan è un ragazzo
affascinante che mi ha fatto veramente
riflettere sulle cose importanti di cui
ho bisogno che sono tutte le cose che
lui non mi dà mai ecco ma cosa stai
dicendo senti patrick quando mai mandato
un messaggio con scritto ti amo e mi
mandi sono i link dei video di fantozzi
dai ma guarda ma guarda che incredibile
ma tua idea che mi hai fatto il verso a
me ma vuoi mettere con te che ti baci
con un altro ma chi bacia patrick o sono
avuto un intesa dai matin la chiami
intesa quella vi siete baciati in bocca
no non è un bacio in bocca patrica e un
bacio sulle labbra e diverso io questi
video li ho visti al pineto
macché pineto che hai pigneto intanto
non pineto e tp network
vabbè dai fine to be ne tu stessa cosa
dai comunque sai qual è il problema
patrick parliamo due lingue diverse
me ne sono accorto tu non sai cos'è
l'amore non lo sai
allora ragazzi mi sembra di capire che
avete tue idee dell'amore completamente
diverse domanda di rito
valeria tu vuoi uscire da tentation
island vip con o senza patrick allora
simona io voglio uscire attenendovi
dentro tutto quello che ho provato in
questo percorso voglio uscire
sperando di trovare l'amore quindi
voglio uscire senza patrick e tu patrick
idem a valérie patrick auguro
riconoscere la seconda metà della mela
passiamo adesso un'altra coppia quella
di andrea zenga e della fidanzata
alessandra anche per loro è arrivato il
momento del falò di confronto finale
ciao andrea benvenuto al falò di
confronto finale ecco che il sapore
hanno avuto questi giorni questi 21
giorni per te più giorni molto forti e
sono molto teso
non so neanche che persone aspettarmi
quindi fronde va bene andrea allora non
ci resta altro che aspettare l'arrivo di
alessandra
non so se tu abbia la minima idea di
quello che ho visto penso che tu abbia
visto che mi sono divertita e sono stata
bene che ho resistito 21 giorni
io ho visto tutt'altro visto lui che ti
parlava continuamente all'orecchio ma è
colpa mia se mi diceva le cose
l'orecchio e ho detto mille volte che
sono entrata qui dentro fidanzata ma chi
vuoi prendere per il culo se so cambiata
in qualche modo emotivo non è che mi
sono svegliata da un giorno all'altro ti
sei fatta pure toccare culo ma che non
l'hai visto che lo scavo non assurdo
guarda due c'è il coraggio di venire qui
dopo 70 cose che vi siete detti al
microfono
io ho mai detto niente sull'orecchio mai
ma c'è il coraggio ha il coraggio ho mai
risposto io ma tu veramente vieni qua è
nelle cose palesi ti sei fatta dieci
giorni riflettevo quello mi ha
conosciuto di più lui 20 giorni che tu
in due anni e mezzo ma tu dopo tutto
quello che hai fatto viene dalla colpa a
me io ammetto che so cambiata perché mi
ha fatto cambiare tu no mi dispiace non
ci credo tu mi hai mai dimostrato
qualcosa in bagno e mezzo io l'ho fatto
per l'arte una svegliata andrea io
volevo crescere insieme a te tu invece è
riservata dopo quattro giorni cazzi tuoi
ragazzi ma voi queste cose non ve le
siete mai dette prima
no mai falsa fino alla fine
mi sembra di capire che questo rapporto
che alessandra avuto con il tentatore
andrea cerioli sta mettendo un po in
discussione tutto simona non è la
scontata in sé
io non ho preso un ascoltata io ho
conosciuto una persona che mi ha capito
dall'inizio alla fine
adesso addirittura dopo che lei si è
fatta la storia con quello viene fuori
che è colpa mia
ragazzi io direi che devo fare la
domanda di rito e tanti auguri che oggi
il tuo compleanno ea ieri è andrea tu
vuoi uscire da questo programma con
alessandra o da solo io ho avuto troppe
mancanze di rispetto per quella che era
la nostra storia e io mi fido più di lei
alessandra tu cosa provi per andrea io
l'ho sempre amato inganni e mezzo fatto
tantissimo per lui e non lo riconosco
non è solo i suoi occhi questi cattivi
andrea tu confermi la tua decisione di
uscire da solo
sì io esco da solo non ci credo di trevi
che non ci credo anche il viaggio nei
sentimenti di andrea alessandra è giunto
al capolinea
si conclude qui la prima edizione di
tentation island in non mi resta altro
che salutarvi e dirvi che per quanto
riusciate a spiare il vostro amore è
solo ascoltando il vostro cuore che
riuscirete a trovare la strada giusta
vi ricordo che se non l'avete ancora
fatto dovete assolutamente iscrivervi al
mio canale e cliccare sulla campanella
vicino al tasso di iscrizione per
rimanere sempre aggiornati e per essere
i primi a commentare i video eseguite vi
su tutti gli altri social instagram
facebook e tic toc
io rimango un bacione ci vediamo alla
prossima edizione
adoro
baci stellari